hi today we're looking at batch
normalization accelerating deep network
training by reducing internal Cove area
chipped by Sergey I off and Christians
get as skittish is he ready yeah not my
not the best pronounce ur Sajid e closed
off alright so this is a bit of an older
paper and it's I think it's still good
to look at it it's relevant and people
just kind of row batch normalization
into networks and maybe don't really
know what it's doing so let's look at it
so what these people argue is that in a
network usually you have structures like
this so if something like that it means
that you're you're lost kind of this a
two layer Network your loss is a
composition of the first layer on the
input to you with parameters theta one
and the second layer with parameters
theta two so conceptually that would
look something like this you have your
input
maybe it's an image right and you put it
through the network and it becomes some
intermediate representation right that's
X 0 that's x1 and or maybe we'll call it
even
H h1 hidden representation right then
that becomes then through the layer
becomes H 2 and so on right so these the
this stuff here these this would be
weight matrices w1 w2 that transform the
image into a new image or whatever so
what they're arguing is that well if you
only consider a single layer like the
first layer here it's kind of the same
if you only consider the second layer
with the h1 now as the input right it's
pretty natural to see each layer of the
neural network is kind of like its own
transformation taking
inputs and producing some outputs so
what people usually do with the very
first input here with your data in
machine learning generally is so-called
whitening the data which means that they
have this over here usually data is
whitened I can't find it but what it
means is you basically wanna if you have
data let's say here is a coordinated
access if 2d data and you wanna you
might want to do a kind of a linear
regression on it and you have data
that's kind of like that alright it it
suits you to transform this data in to
by first of all looking where it's mean
is mean is about here and subtracting
that so here here and then kind of
dividing by its standard deviation in
each direction so there's a standard
deviation here and there is a standard
deviation here so you would transform
this data into something like maybe
something like this so you see that the
mean the mean is now in the middle and
the it's not so elongated anymore
so if you have a much easier time to
kind of learn learn something on this
data then on this date over here simply
because our classifier is usually tend
to rely on like inner products and if
you if you do an inner product here you
have one of these vectors here and you
do some inner product it's always going
to be far away from from the mean and
thereby the inner products are going to
be large no matter what right whereas
here if you take a random one and then
another run so two round if you take two
random points here there are two vectors
from the mean are almost the same
whereas if you take two random points
here they tend to look you know
uniformly in
in the directions so it's kind of the
sense we know that machine learning
methods work better if you whiten the
data first so these people ask hey why
why do why do we only do this at the
very beginning right why don't we why if
each layer is basically takes its input
and learn something each layer is
basically a machine learning method why
don't we just whiten the data to every
single layer or you know every single
sub component of a deep network and
that's the kind of basic step here so
they argue how this has been kind of
tried before or what kind of methods you
would usually get and why these aren't
so good mainly because you kind of need
to intermingle this whitening with
training the network and thereby if you
just go about this naively then you
would not you are not um you would kind
of produce artifacts from training so
that's that's this section this section
here where they argue that it's not
really you can't really go about this
super naively but what they do isn't
super complicated but they just do it in
a smart way so we'll jump directly to
that what they say is okay let's look at
what they call normalization of you have
mini-batch statistics all right let's
say we have a some some D dimensional
input X right and we're just gonna look
at per dimension so we only care about
per per individual dimension
normalization all right so what are we
get what do we need to do when it take
the KF dimension we're going to subtract
from it the mean of the KF dimension
within a mini batch right within a mini
batch of data so many much maybe
something like 32 examples or a hundred
examples or something like this and then
we'll divide by the variance of that
mini batch
[Music]
so this is this is done over here in in
basic so you compute mu B mu of the
mini-batch which is simply the empirical
mean of that of the data at that
particular layer and then you compute
Sigma squared B which is simply the the
empirical estimate of the variance of
that of computed on that particular
mini-batch and then you transform your
data by subtracting that and by dividing
it by this and this is this constant
here is simply to prevent from dividing
to by you know to to small values so you
get like in numerical problems so what
does it do
it does basically what we what we did
above but now what they say is okay we
want to make sure that this
transformation can potentially you know
represent the identity because sometimes
or like a natural natural if you had to
do something with your input when giving
it to the next layer like the very
baseline is to do nothing to it right to
do the identity transform but if you do
if you do this you probably won't end up
with the identity transform except if
the mean is exactly 0 and the variance
is exactly 1 right so what they say is
okay we'll also introduce two new
parameters to this here is this gamma
and this beta here and these are learned
like other parameters in the network we
learn the parameter gamma and better and
gamma and beta are simply gamma is
simply a scalar that this transformed x
is x and beta is simply a scalar that is
then added to it so in each dimension of
your hidden representation you basically
learn how
to scale it and how to shift it scale
and shift after you've done the
normalization so first first you do the
normalization where is it
right first you go from this type of
data to this type of data and then you
say well maybe it's actually more
beneficial to you know have it not
centered or whatever said so that the
network can actually learn them to
transform this somewhere this might seem
this might seem redundant but it's
really powerful because what you're
basically saying is that okay this
probably isn't the best you know
distribution this probably is better but
if the network kind of if the
backpropagation algorithm or the
training algorithm decides that this
first representation was actually useful
it has the option of going back but it
also has the option of going to any
other kind of form of distribution so so
it's it's pretty powerful in terms of
what it does okay it's not really
correct here that it has the power to go
to any distribution because it's only
kind of her dimension scalar that it
learns but still eat the potential to
transform the distribution by these
learned scalars is is pretty big all
right so basically that's it that's
that's that's the whole that's the whole
shebang you normalize your inputs to
each layer by this formula and then you
introduce new parameters that you learn
along with your network parameters so
this kind of has some implications first
of all one implication is this here
if you build a batch norm into your
network it kind of learns this this post
beta which is basically a bias parameter
if you think of a traditional kind of
fully connected layer this isn't a fully
connected layer because this scalar here
is only per dimension but the bias in a
fully connected layer is also just per
dimension so the beta is equal to a bias
and a fully connected layer so if you
have a batch normalization after or
after a after a fully connected or
convolutional a or anything that can or
sometimes has a bias parameter it's
almost not worth it
to kind of learn both so you would
rather just only have the one from the
Batchelor normalization and leave and
use the convolution or fully connect
layer without a bias so that's kind of
one implication another implication is
we have just lost the kind of the the
ability to have deterministic test time
inference so much like dropout which is
kind of random dropping out of nodes
here we have quantities that depend on
the mini batch so not only the
individuals sample but they actually
depend on what other samples are
randomly selected to be trained with
that particular sample so that's that's
kind of awkward if you kind of want to
have some deterministic reproducible
thing at test time so what people do is
and here this is discussed what people
do is
while training they use these quantities
they did the quantities we just
discussed but they keep kind of a
running average over them so what I
would do is in each mini batch I would
compute this mini batch mean and this
mini batch variance and I would keep
quantities I'll keep running averages of
them right and at test time I'm gonna
plug in these running averages so
there's nothing dependant on the mini
batch anymore
that's so that that's that's pretty neat
trick I think and you can even imagine
like at the end of your network training
simply using these here to kind of
fine-tune the weights to these exact
parameters so that's one thing that's
that's kind of you have to pay attention
to so in usually in neural network
libraries there are there are parameters
you can set whether or not this network
is in train mode or in test mode and
depending on that the batch norm layer
will use the mini batch statistics or
will use the kind of over dataset
statistics all right the second thing is
training so how do you actually train
this thing because now you can't you
can't just right we we started with our
with our multi-layer network up here
right f2f1 right first I'm gonna put my
things through f1 and then I put my
things through f2 right and the the back
propagation here is is quite easy so let
me get rid of this the backdrop here is
quite easy you go oh and maybe you want
to drive it by theta1 right so you first
going to drive it by the hidden
representation one and then the hidden
representation one with
like two theta one so the hidden
representation would be whatever comes
out of here or h1 sorry not I and so on
so you kind of chain rule your way
through here but now in between these
layers here you have these patch norm
things and so that the authors discuss
how we now do back propagation in the
face of these things so here is
basically what they discuss it actually
pays to to have a graph of what's going
on so here is X this is the input to our
layer right so what do we compute from X
we compute mu let's just call it me or
maybe it's called here all right
this is the mean of of all the X's so we
this is X X I until X well X one until X
n this is the mini-batch we compute the
mean and then from this and from this we
can compute this estimate of the
variance right we need both all right so
we now have the mean and the variance
over the mini-batch so we're going to
take one of these X's just a if one
right and we're going to use this and
this to compute X what compute X is it
called hat yeah probably
it's called X hat right yeah we saw
about X hat so X hat is X X hat I is x I
minus mu B divided by Sigma squared be
the square root of it plus this kind of
little constant here well leave away the
little little constant for clarity sake
actually it's in the calculations here
but
so um then we have new parameter gamma
right and we're going to use it and our
X have to compute and also this beta
here to compute y hat why or why just
why and of course this is I this is I
right so and this here is our final
output of the layer so you can see now
the back propagation paths if you go
through here so the back propagation
path if we have some loss coming in here
we back prop through why I right so here
is the L the loss to why I that's here
right so if we want the for example the
back prop with respect to beta what we
do is we simply and this is this is over
the mini batch of course we simply back
prop here through this path so in our in
our formula for beta there should be
only mentioned why I and that's what we
see here right in our formula for gamma
there should only be mention of Y I so
because the path leads only through why
I oh no I'm sorry actually because they
of the what I mean is of the derivative
with respect to Y I of course the we
also have to pain take into attention
that this is multiplied here by this X
hat I wear of course that's not the case
when we just add something because the
derivative of two of of an addition like
X plus B with respect to B disregards X
whereas if it's x times B it doesn't
this restored this record X all right so
if we yeah so you can you can go back so
the interesting that basically comes
when we want to find out okay how
because here is
here is another layer right down here
somewhere there is another layer and we
basically want to know this input here
to the next layer how do we compute it
in the face of this mess here because we
it's not it's not so easy right
so you have to see we have three paths
here we go back through X and let me get
rid of this blue one we go we go back
through X hat directly to X we go one
path is through here and one path is
through this this mu so basically have
to compute derivatives with respect to
Sigma squared and mu and for that we
need to derivative with with respect to
X hat so basically the way back prop
works is you just find all paths from
where you are to where you want to go
and then you you kind of intuitively
compute this so this one here's the easy
T easiest as you see here they did it on
top
well first they did this one which is
simply going from Y to X hat I start
then they go from X hat I to Sigma
squared which simply involves kind of
the reverse operations of how you got it
this is simply a derivative formula here
of the of the division by square root
then you can use this you can use this
quantity here to compute that so
basically you just go in reverse of how
you computed the operations in the first
place we said we needed mu be to compute
Sigma squared V now we need the
derivative with respect to Sigma square
B in order to compute the derivative to
MU B and once you have to only see the
addition here the ad here is the fact
that oops is the fact that two things
contribute to MU B so two
paths lead to veto movie one path is
from from here and one path is through
here right so here there should be a
green since two paths you have two
components to your derivative and you
add each of them so that's how that's
going to be and then this here with
respect to this X here we have three
paths right because we have three arrows
going out of X I one here one here and
one here
so I have to take into account all of
them alright so this one it's pretty
easy that's the first one then the
second one sorry this the second one
goes through this UV which we've already
computed and the third one goes through
the Sigma which we've also already
computed right and these are added
because all the paths you have to all
add all the paths in the backdrop
algorithm maybe we'll do a actually
video on that prop later too to get to
really dive into how this works
and finally they they compute these
these we've already discussed so in
essence the whole thing is
differentiable you just have to kind of
pay attention how to do it but the whole
thing is differentiable and thereby you
can basically back drop through a
network that has these batch normal ears
in a built-in so that's pretty cool I
just want to quickly jump over to the
results and yeah keep in mind this paper
is from 2015
so networks weren't that big back then
we didn't know that much about training
yet but the interesting thing is they
basically discovered look we can we can
have drastically fewer steps in order to
reach the same accuracies and these are
kind of the activations of the network
over the course of training so with
a platinum you see especially at the
beginning there's large fluctuations in
the activations and because because they
use batch norm now there is no such
thing so basically the reason for that
is pretty is pretty simple right while
you learn and you learn your layered
representation here let's say there's X
and X is fed through layers and there is
hidden representations each in between
right so you're trying to learn all
these parameters let's say this one here
w3 but at the beginning of training
everything is kind of prone to shifting
around a lot so when you change w1 that
kind of changes the entire distribution
of your hidden representations after the
fact so basically whatever you learn for
w3 is now already almost obsolete
because you've changed w1 basically and
w3 was kind of assuming that its inputs
would would remain the same because
that's what you assume in machine
learning your input distribution is kind
of the same so that's why at the
beginning of training you see these kind
of large variances and with batch norm
this tends to go away so that's pretty
cool they also kind of show they mainly
show that they can reach the same
accuracies as other as other training
methods but with much much fewer steps
and they can go much higher learning
rates than others so um because because
of that so that's pretty cool
I encourage you to you to check out the
rest of the paper use batch norm in your
network sometimes works sometimes
doesn't work strangely enough but you
know I guess that's just a matter of
experimentation alright
that was it for me bye bye